Girl Scouts of America caused some
controversy after deciding to march in
president Trump's inaugural parade were
people that thought that was like a
political statement from the Girl Scouts
well despite any criticism the Girl
Scouts now are doubling down on their
support of Donald Trump you can tell
just by looking at some of the new Girl
Scout cookie flavors for this year for
example there's doe see don't get
abortions
yeah there's illegal Samoans that's not
something they always popular fake news
tunes those aren't good there's not fit
enough mints you can't be yeah
there's white white and whites that's a
good cookie there's a honker yum-yum's
oh those are delicious
[Applause]
hey settle down you were vetted you were
all vetted before you got in here
another flavor deleted oat mail servers
those are good and finally chicks Ohio
that's a good cookie
having fun what's this having fun no too
much to power did it go too far did it
go too far
I hope I didn't go too far
you